oh you know what we did last night
because it was we're on or on season
three episode one at games of throne we
had uh we were betty hannas
what's that story man benny hannah's
benny hannah is just fried rice isn't it
no i don't how dare you the hibachi
where it's like you get cut or they're
cooking from
flaming young yeah but they just you
they postmates are dropping off
it comes in this [ __ ] like so what do
you order what are you yeah benihana's
like i've never had hobbies they're
fillet like you can get the flaming
young the shrimp
then comes the spicy fried rice it's
okay fine noodles
so it's just i don't [ __ ] with the
noodles it's bougie chinese food that's
it
japanese japanese but i mean nice when
they cook it in front of you
the the fried rice with the butter and
everything and the onions it just smells
so good and it tastes so good when you
eat it right there as a 30
mid 30s year old man when you go there
and yeah i
feel bad for the guy who's like oh here
we go
and they have like the onion and they
put the flame out it's a volcano
do you want the stupid performance or
not because everyone if if there's not a
kid at the table it's like
what are you doing yeah it's an i see
flick a [ __ ] shrimp in your hat
but it is cool when you watch it though
ah man the first couple times the main
reason why you go to benihana i don't
know anyone who actually goes in just
for
really i imagine i imagine i i agree
with you i imagine people go for the
performance yeah
that's what i imagine really the food is
pretty cool
right he'll yeah they do they do it in
your mouth sometimes
yeah yeah i wanna i wanna option where i
don't have any of that [ __ ] you know
they use 150 i'm so excited now
did you know that for what for i don't
know they use 151 to clean it or
something i don't know something
you can get they they uh oh you guys get
the fire
yeah that's why mm-hmm and then he goes
ah
151 uh what's his name dj aoki
his dad created brocky what uh
yep he has one in his backyard damn yep
that guy's legit that's where his family
made their money it was benihana
that place is great sharpening pokemon
yeah that place is [ __ ] great
i don't know a single asian person who's
ever been to benihana and went back for
food that's the reason why i just think
it's like a touristy attraction
for people like if you don't like asian
food that's like probably the best
introduction to it
i would say cream barbecue no that
barbecue is kind of like uh the same
thing it's kind of performative
it's not really and it's kind of like
basically it's food you know just like
that
came out way way for uh before yeah
before i even started going to korean
barbecue
but i would go benny hannah korean
barbecue yeah for sure now
100 percent you know my mom worked at
benihana for like over
20 years i think she retired she she
retired as a waitress how do you feel
about hating on it
yeah that's fine that's why you know
your mom's life did they give your mom
any benefits
no i don't i don't know betty i just
heard a bunch she she served kobe a lot
kobe had his own table in there toby
right right yeah he loved going there
like yeah of course he's the
[ __ ] mom yeah his own section he used
to always go there with his wife and his
kids yes
kids love it yeah the newport beach one
yeah because it's
lit is that where your mom worked she
retired there yeah
oh that's she was a waitress for a very
long time yeah
server am like a cashier person for the
waitress is there it's like you get the
drinks that's about it
well they have to do the food stuff i
mean there's also foods that you can
order from the kitchen as well
like sushi stuff that they don't they
don't have sushi now
they have sushi yeah sushi yeah i think
they've ever had that sushi for a while
okay you and stephanie
last night yeah we were at castle